hi there today we'll look at rethinking
attention
with performers by researchers of
google the university of cambridge
deepmind and the alan turing institute
this paper is yet another paper in the
quest
to make transformers more performant and
what better name to give to a technique
than the
per former so the performer
performers are a new kind of class of
models
they try to approximate the transformer
if you don't know what a transformer is
i've done like a
a ton of videos on transformers on
attention mechanisms
and you can there's more than enough
material to
look that up today we'll talk about
performers
and the performers as i already said
they approximate
transformers and they do so without
running into the classic transformer
bottleneck
which is that the attention matrix in
the transformer
is has space and compute requirements
that are quadratic in the size of the
input and that limits
how much input you can put into the
model so
it kind of limits how long of text you
can input if you
work with text or how big your images
are that you can work with
uh this is all kind of bad at
when you use transformers so the
performers get around this by this
technique
they call fast attention via positive
orthogonal
random features abbreviated favor plus
they use this
favor plus to get around it and what's
interesting is that the
favor plot i'll just call it favor
this um fast attention it
it is potentially useful beyond
transformers
so it's apparently been here developed
in the
realm of the transformers but they say
which may be of independent interest
for scalable kernel methods you'll see
what they do is they approximate the
attention
matrix by decomposing it
but they do it in a special way and
they do it in the in the way um if you
know what random fourier features are
maybe you can kind of think think ahead
a little bit if not we'll we'll get into
it for sure
uh i think honestly this might be
one of the enabling one of the next mini
breakthroughs in
in deep learning not big breakthrough
but kind of mini breakthrough
i remember a time when we used uh
sigmoid and tan h non-linearities
believe it or not you
young kids at the beginning of deep or
not the beginning of deep learning but
before deep learning really took off
um it was a sensible thing to use
soft max and tan h non-linearities
everywhere in
your neural networks because well first
of all they were like
differentiable so that was cool and then
um you know it was sort of how nature
does it with the step
function in like it was an approximation
to the step
function in a true neuron and so on
and it was just kind of well motivated
so people thought that must be
the way to go but then of course uh
turned out that relus
are much easier much more stable give
much better results and so on don't
saturate
all these cool things this here is kind
of the
it's it see it feels like the same thing
because right now
we're doing this soft max thing in
attention
and it's very important because it
normalizes the attention matrix right it
gives you kind of this thing that comes
out is kind of a distribution
over the inputs and so on so it's well
motivated and
you may be able to see but also as the
sigmoid is it's kind of has this
exponential thing in there
and the favor algorithm is going to
approximate this soft max thing
but it can be used to approximate much
more
so maybe you know we're going to find
that if we swap out these the
non-linearity in there
we might be able to build much better
transformers
or whatever the model will be called
performers i guess they already do this
here with reloose in this very paper
so the performer is going to be
fully compatible with regular
transformer and with strong theoretical
guarantees
unbiased or nearly unbiased estimation
of the attention matrix uniform
convergence and low
estimation variance so the difference of
the performer here is going to be
that there have been methods before that
decompose the attention matrix into low
rank matrices
but um those either
don't work or they kind of rely on on
priors
like the you're assuming that your
attention matrix has a certain structure
if it doesn't it sort of fails this
method here is going to be an unbiased
estimator
and it's going to sort of converge to
the attention matrix if you add more of
these random features
okay this is fed here like provably not
relying on any priors fully compatible
with regular transformers which means
that you can take a transformer
checkpoint
and sort of plug it into this framework
and then you just have to fine tune a
little bit
um to sort of use the checkpoint of a
regular transformer
which is pretty cool right so we'll go
through the paper it's quite a heavy
paper it's quite a math heavy paper
we won't go through all of it um i just
kind of want you to get the idea of what
these
performers do what the reasoning behind
it is and how
you might be able to kind of work with
them or extend them where it's
where it's going from here as always
if you like content like this don't
hesitate to share it out and
tell your friends about it all right so
the problem with attention
or the problem with transformers is like
i've done this a million times and you
can go look it up but
if you want to map a sequence of layer
l into a sequence uh or a set
or what not of layer l plus one and you
need to compute these attention
weights right so the attention weights
are going to be
from each token here to each token in
the next layer
you're going to compute one of these
weights
right so there is there is this matrix
is called a
the attention matrix and a is going to
be of size
l by l and that is a problem if you have
long sequences right you can already see
this so the way
that this a comes to be is that
conceptually the upper layer like it's
all the same layer but
conceptually the upper layer emits
something
that are called queries and the lower
layer emits something that are called
keys and values now the keys and the
queries they go together
into matrices so it multiply the keys
and the queries then
you run this through and this is the
problem you run this
through a soft max non-linearity to
basically get a distribution and then
you multiply it by the values so
the query key matrix this attention
matrix
it will tell you how to aggregate the
values
all right if it weren't for the soft max
so you can you can think if if these
if these the dimensions of the queries
and keys and values let's call it
small d then the dimensionality here
would be something like here you'd have
l
by d here you'd have d by l for the
transposed
and then here you'd have l by d
so because you have to do the softmax
you have to compute this first which
gives you this l by
l which is the terrible thing however
if you could if you could if
somehow decompose the soft max operation
you could first
do keys and values which will give you a
d by d
matrix and then you could multiply it by
the q matrix right
which would be much much much more easy
if
d is smaller than l certainly it
wouldn't grow
quadratically in l it would just grow
linearly
in in space and time so here this is
formulated out the attention mechanism
right here the attention mechanism
is made of queries keys and values and
it's given
by this formula right here now there is
a bit of a
technicality i wasn't exactly correct in
what
a is so here they
they say they i called
this thing here a okay they are very
specific what they mean by
a by a they simply mean the
exponential function of the normalized
queries times keys
and then to get the actual softmax you
have to normalize
by here so d which is
so you see the inverse is made here d
is constructed from a and normalizes a
but the normalization is of
secondary importance the important part
here is
that this exponential
cannot be easily decomposed right it's
it's not like you can decompose the
inner multiplication into
two exponentials or something otherwise
the problem would be solved
so what is this paper doing it's exactly
what i just said was
impossible um so you have this matrix a
right here and you multiplied by v i
guess again forget about the
normalization by now
it will decompose a into
the query q prime and k prime
now they are called prime because they
are not the queries and the keys
because we've just said the queries and
the keys they go into the exponential so
it's going to be that k uh sorry
q prime times k prime transposed
is going to be approximately equal to
exponential function of
q times k maybe normalized by
square root of d but you can see that
this here isn't decomposable and yet
they decompose it
and the question is how because there
have been papers
before that try to decompose the
attention
matrix i think linformer
maybe and there is also the
reformer which uses lsh and so on so
there have been a number of tricks but
they all
don't perform as well which this paper
also shows empirically
and they all rely on certain assumptions
of the attention matrix and they all
are not unbiased estimators in
general this paper is going to be an
unbiased estimator
and they do this via sort of a kernel
framework so what
they they first of all they make
this problem more general they say
we have our attention matrix a the
ijf entry is going to be the query
i the key j
and some some kernel function of that
okay in our case
this is going to be the right x of
query times key like this
sorry the other way around transpose
transposed
times key the inner product of that
however
you can think of any sort of of kernel
function
okay so um
[Music]
yeah if if i'm i'm not going i'm not
going to try to explain
uh more details into kernels we had a
fantastic machine learning
street talk so if you don't know about
this this is our podcast
machine learning street talk where alex
stanlek
explained kernels in great detail and
with very very precise language
and very understandable as well so
what i'm going to say is that they allow
you to do
things like this so
you can think of kernels as kind of
connecting two things they allow you
they represent an inner product in
some other space okay so the kernel
function
of two inputs right here will be
equal to some some inner product
of the two inputs when pulled through
this function
phi right here and that's what we're
going to
use now usually usually
when you learn about kernels you do it
in this way
you say we would like to compute in this
very high dimensional space but we can't
we can't do inner products we can't map
this function
phi explicitly so we're going to
instead use this kernel right here this
kernel function
and that's going to be equal if you pick
the right kernel function for the
particular phi
in this paper we're going to do it the
other way around
because we say well this thing here is
this is the soft max function and that's
just
a a beast right we can't possibly
compute that
however if we could find out
what inner product that corresponds to
what other space we could just go to
that other space and perform
an inner product and this thing
over here is linear right this is a
linear function
this here is the nonlinear function this
is our softmax
so you can see that by going in this way
by finding what is the higher or the
the phi function for the soft max kernel
we can construct all of this attention
business
in a linear fashion and
that's what this paper does what it
allows you to do is
it allows you to find these q
and k q prime and k prime matrices
such that as over here right this is the
kernel function
and this here is linear
and then you can simply first multiply k
by
v or k prime by v and then you can
multiply q
by k and that will alleviate you of
having this giant attention
matrix so how do they do it if you
again if you know about random fourier
features this is going to be
very much or very similar thing right
here
um they're not going to explicitly
construct
the high dimensional space such that
this is exactly equal
but they're going to construct an
approximation
and the approximation you can make
arbitrarily
good and you do that via the following
you say
so here you see this
is how do i have to map something
into this other dimensional space where
this whole soft max business is just a
linear operation so what you would do
ultimately is you would take your
queries you would map it through this
file okay and you would take your
keys and you would also map it through
this phi and this will give you
query prime and this will give you key
prime
right so and then in the higher in the
higher lower whatever dimensional space
you would take the inner product
and the inner product between the two is
going
to approximately be as if you had mults
of the inner product
is going to be approximately as if you
had taken
the original q and k multiplied them
and put them through a soft max
how do we do it so here we define what
the function needs to look like
such that this holds the function again
they go very general here the function
in general is going to look
like the following so you have one
function
here that's called h that is a function
of your input and it's in front it's a
deterministic function of your input
and you also have a normalization factor
so this is kind of
it's it's kind of a factor in front of
it you see
that here comes a vector so this
is a vector right we are mapping this to
use a
sum dimensional space and
this is the vector now it's a bit you
have to
pay a bit of attention so inside this
vector
you have l different sub
vectors they're all concatenated after
each other okay so you have
so you see here this where the f this is
f1
and then f2 f3 f4 and so on until
fl okay so you have all these sub
vectors um
it doesn't matter ultimately you just
concatenate them all but it's
important uh to just keep in mind within
each of these vectors within each of
these sub vectors you
always have the same repeated term okay
you have this w times your x
so the inner product between w and x you
can see there's w1 through
wm or omega i think it's an omega
and again in the in each sub vector you
have
this repeated so what are these omegas
first of all
the omegas are random vectors
drawn for from some distribution
now in practicality this is going to be
a
normal distribution like this one here
an isotropic normal distribution
so and the the other part here is what
are the
f's so the the f's f1 through
fl are going to be functions
deterministic functions
so a in example they gave right here
if one is the sine function f2 is the
cosine function
and then you have to specify h and h in
this particular example
is one but it can be a function of x
here it's just the identity sorry not
the identity the
constant function one so
let's break this
a little down so we have x
and x is going to be a vector x as i
said x is going to be like
one of the queries here or one of the
one of the keys here
one one of them right one column or one
row
however you conceptualize it and we
wonder how do we want to map so
x is going to be some
vector okay then this is an
ugly vector let's draw it like this
x is a vector
then what we're going to do is we're
going to take
a bunch of omegas now it's important
that the omegas are random
so they come from this isotropic normal
distribution
but they're going to remain the same
throughout the algorithm there is a
method to
resample them but just conceptualize
that at the beginning of the algorithm
you choose these omegas and then you
fix them okay so the omegas are going to
be
also vectors which are
random just a bunch of random vectors
okay
let's take three what you're going to do
is you're going to compute the inner
product between your x
and each of the omegas so inner product
between your x and each of the omega so
this gives you
omega 1 x omega 2
x omega 3 x
so the inner product this is going to be
this is this is going to be
numbers okay and then
you're going to have a collection of
functions
so these are going to be functions
maybe function one
is going maybe here the sine function
function two
is going to be the cosine function okay
now you are going
to take each you to make a table
you're going to take each of these
products you computed
and put them through each of the
functions so this is going to be
sine of w omega 1
x cosine of
omega 1 x
sine of omega 2 x and so on
okay and then you're going to
take this table and you're going to
flatten it
to a big vector so sine
omega 1 x cosine
or no sine first the ordering they do
it doesn't matter as long as you always
do it the same omega
2 x and so on right until
you have here cosine of omega 3
x so that's the vector they're
constructing
and these are those random features okay
so this here is going to be the vector
that you're
constructing what you do is basically
geometrically your x
is like somewhere here and
it's a bit hard to draw in low
dimensional space because you don't get
the intuition
but this is if this is your x you're
going to choose a bunch of
these omegas these omegas are going to
be randomly
sampled from a uniform gaussian so this
is omega 1 maybe oh my god 2
omega 3 omega 4. and
you're going to compute the inner
product between um
between any of the two okay so you're
going to be
essentially computing the projections
onto each other or the angle however you
want to conceptualize it
the angle of this to each of the two
of the omegas and then you're going to
make
a features out of these angles
right so this will sort of tell you
how your vector stands to each of these
random features now the reason i say
it's
difficult in low dimension is because
now i have more omegas
than the dimensionality which is two
right here
and and this makes no sense right as
soon as i have two vectors that are not
collinear
in two-dimensional space i can if i
project
x onto them like like this oh sorry
like if i project x onto both of them i
already have
x fully represented right there is
there's no need to
have more of them however if you are in
super duper high dimensional space
and you don't you don't have as many
features
then you get some interesting
approximation properties
namely so this was an example right we
don't always have the sine
and the cosine here this is purely an
example
you can only have one function you see
like this
f1 you don't need two functions you can
have one you can have
many okay and you can choose
how many omegas you sample that is a
parameter
so yeah you have a couple of choices i
want to make it clear the choice
of h so the choice of
h and f they go hand in hand
the choice of h and the f's determine
what the phi function is okay
so the choice of h and f determine
which kernel function this phi function
corresponds to
if you construct it like this so
by choosing the correct functions you
tell
the function which kernel you would like
to approximate
and then by sampling the omegas the more
omegas you sample
the more accurately you approximate that
kernel okay and then you can give some
approximation guarantees
as they say so the soft max kernel
is given by this thing here which we've
already seen
okay and now how do we approximate the
soft max kernel
and they show that right here the
softmax kernel is
approximated by this thing right here
so it's a bit of a a
ugly formula and it contains this
gaussian kernel
the gauss kernel so they say
if we choose h equals to 1
so just a constant factor
and this f1 and f2 to the sine and
cosine
and in if we choose d the distribution
to be a normal distribution isotropic
around the mean
this is the gaussian kernel and then we
simply have to choose
h differently uh this factor in front
to make it into the softmax kernel so as
long as we put this factor in front
you can see that this here represent
this here represents an
inner product right so you have to kind
of um
think of decomposition so if you
put you can see f1 the sine f2 the
cosine which is
this makes it the gaussian kernel and
then
this factor in front of it here 2 for
h this makes it now the soft max kernel
so if we choose
h and f like this
then when we map our queries and
keys through
if we map our queries and keys through
the phi
function and then make
the inner product between them okay
like here that will approximate
depending on how many omegas we've
sampled better or worse
the approximate the result as
if we had multiplied them first
and then put them through the softmax
function
all right so this you can see how this
becomes much easier because
we can independently put them through
the phi okay
and then it's just a linear operation
which allows us to do
our trick where we multiply k and v
first
and then multiply by q instead of the
other way around which we're forced to
do when we apply the soft max
this was a long a long way to get here
but i hope you're with this
and this is this is pretty
straightforward actually so far
now renormalization we can take care of
that
easily but there is a problem and this
is they argue this hasn't been proposed
so far because it doesn't
work like this so even though you
approximate this kernel
fairly well it's it's a bad
approximation
and they they say here
there is however a caveat here the
attention module from one
constructs for each token a convex
combination of value vectors with
coefficients given as corresponding
re-normalized kernel scores that is why
kernels producing non-negative scores
are used
applying random feature maps with
potentially negative dimension values
leads to unstable behaviors especially
when kernel scores
close to zero which is the case for lots
of entries of a
corresponding to not relevant tokens are
approximated
by estimators with large variants in
such regions this results in abnormal
behaviors eg
negative diagonal value renormalizers
and consequently either
completely prevents training or leads to
sub-optimal models
so what they're saying is that when you
use soft max
you always always uh get positive values
right so if i have a bunch of vectors
uh or a bunch of numbers this is you
know positive number
negative number very positive number
negative number
and i run it through a soft max
um i will get out a distribution
right like this or really big sorry
the soft max will scale that up i will
get out a positive district like a kind
of a histogram okay
and now i'm trying to approximate this
by this formula right here and you can
see these are these are vectors
which gives me sine and cosine
coefficients and i
linearly multiply two vectors together
which definitely means i can get
negative entries and so on so
the renormalization then has to somehow
maybe take care of that
and it says especially especially
around zero when the original soft max
matrix would have values close to zero
this approximation is really bad and has
high
variance and they also argue
a lot of attention vectors are close to
zero because we know that attention is
is sort of sparsify uh just by the fact
of what how the soft max works
it exaggerates the largest inner
products and it really dampens the low
inner products okay
actually i might not even have done this
correctly here if it's
if it's very negative i'm not sure
in any case they say that's why this
doesn't work because it has such high
variance it's a good approximation
but has such high variance in the wrong
places
namely around zero where most values are
so they call this these s the sm the
soft max approximation
with m sampled features trig
because it uses the sine and cosine
functions
and now they're trying to
remedy this and for that
they propose a different decomposition
so
a different approximation to the soft
max kernel
and they say we can also decompose the
soft max or approximate the soft max
kernel
with the following formula and i
look i i'm not going to they have a
proof for this
but this is the formula
you sample again you sample these things
and then you perform
this inner this is the inner product
that approximates the softmax kernel
okay and this is further you can
reduce this to this thing right here
so it's a deterministic matrix
right here this which is given by
that and it's this
cos h so cos h is the hyperbolic tangent
this can be this is so cos h
of x is e to the
x plus e to the minus
x divided by two
okay so this
function um approximates
the softmax and
that's just something you'll have to
take from their proof
however you can now see that this can be
fairly easily represented as an inner
product
you already see it here right um this
you simply this is the the part that
comes from
x and this is the part that comes from y
if you want to note this in our
in our notation earlier again we use
the distribution that we sample the
omegas from is going to be a normal
distribution
and our functions are going to be this h
function is the pre factor it's simply
going to be
the made up of the norm of x and put
through the exponential function
and then we have two options actually
right here i don't even know why they
put the first one
but the second option makes more sense
and there's a bit of a more of a factor
right here
so you have two functions there is x
of u and negative x and x of negative
u as the two functions you remember this
is where we had sine and cosine before
now we have x u and negative x sorry x
of negative u and we can quickly check
that this gives us the same thing so
this h these h functions if we inner
product them
that's going to be to give us the
this what is that even lambda is that a
big lambda
uh matrix right here and
our vector let's just say we sample one
single omega
right so we have our x we sample one
single omega so x
is going to give us a vector with two
sub-vectors right since we have two
functions
each sub-vector is of length one so
the first um is going to be e to the
omega x and the second entry is going to
be
e to the negative omega x
if we put in y through the same or
if as instead of x and y you can think
of queries and keys
um that's going to be oh my god y e
to the negative omega y if we now take
the inner product
that is going to give us um
and i'm resolving the exponentials
already
right here so that's going to give us e
to the
um e to the w
x plus y and here
is going to give us plus e to the
w or sorry the negative w
x plus y and that's the you know
there's a normalization factor uh that's
why the square root of two is here right
so that comes in somewhere here to give
us this normalization factor so this is
exactly
the hyperbolic cosine
of omega times z and z is
x plus y that they say it's somewhere
yeah here
okay so if we choose
f1 and f2 to be this x bu and x negative
u
then we get if we perform the inner
product
we get out exactly this formula number
seven
right here so this is this and
that is an approximation of the
soft max kernel of the soft max function
it's just a different approximation than
before okay and
the cool thing about this approximation
is that
the approximation itself only ever has
positive values so these vectors here
you can see the x the vectors here and
there's of course a four
a factor in front of this right here
which is going to be
also an exponential these are all
exponential so these are all going to be
positive features which is very
very nice and they also show this
theoretically so here this kind of funky
graphic
shows this this is the ratio
of the approximation mistake
okay the ratio of the approximation
mistake
of the of the
original approximation that we discussed
and this new
positive approximation that we just
built right now
and you can see that in parts here it's
fairly similar so this i believe so r
is the ratio so it's fairly flat
right here but there are parts where it
just shoots up
right and in fact they can prove
that um you can see this also right here
so the error of the trig
approximation that shoots up while the
positive
approximation just stays flat or flatter
in these regions they can in fact prove
that the
[Music]
the error of the
yeah so you see the error
if the soft max values go to zero so
that's the problematic regions
the error of the trigonomic
approximation can go to infinity while
the error
of the positive approximation goes to
zero
okay they have a number of theoretical
results in here i think that's one of
the
main ones the fact that uh the
this approximation succeeds where the
other approximation fails
really quickly they also have this
variant here where
they don't build a two vec a two ver or
a vector of
two sub vectors but just one with just
the exponential
function and that is the same thing
because of course if you sample
w you're going to have uh sorry omega if
you sample omega
you're going to have omega as much as uh
negative omega
i believe and and thereby in expectation
you're going to get this uh
hyperbolic cosine again i think that's
the reason
why but this lower this lower
construction here gives you the
hyperbolic cosine
okay so pretty cool we simply use
this approximation we run our queries
right
this their queries and our keys
through this and again we ideally use
more omegas than just
one maybe a bunch the more we use the
better
we obtain a linear function that
approximates the
soft max function uh the more we sample
the more it approximate it
it's unbiased and so on i have a bunch
of variants
of it so variant where you
normalize the omegas which gives you the
regularized soft max kernel which is not
a soft max anymore
but it's a regularized soft max and they
can approximate this
in pretty much the same way except
instead of a normal distribution you use
a uniform
distribution right here
um and they have a bunch of other things
namely uh one other improvement
is that so far we've simply sampled
these w's okay
we sampled the w's from a normal
distribution
like this here they say we can improve
even further
namely we can strictly improve with this
gives us an estimator with strictly
lower variance if we make sure
that the w's we sample are exactly
orthogonal
so they're already approximately
orthogonal if we sample them from a high
dimensional space
but if we make sure that they are
exactly orthogonal
sorry then they are giving us an
even better approximation and you can do
that
by this procedure called the gram
schmidt or orthogonalization or gram
schmidt renormalization procedure
that's a it's a pretty easy procedure
and
it doesn't mess with your unbiasedness
um whenever d is an isotropic
distribution isotropics just means
the same in every direction so like a a
standard
gaussian would fulfill or or a uniform
would fulfill this thing as long as it's
centered
i think maybe even if it's not centered
depends on how you re-normalize
i'm okay this is irrelevant but if you
if you make them exactly orthogonal
say this leads to the first theoretical
results showing that orthogonal random
features can be applied to reduce the
variance of the softmax or gaussian
kernel estimators
for any dimensional ltd rather than just
ace asymptotically for large enough d
as it is the case for previous methods
and leads to the first
exponentially small bounds on large
deviations
probabilities that are strictly smaller
than
for non-orthogonal methods okay
so we're going to end up with a thing
that's
strictly smaller so bounds that are
strictly smaller than
if you don't use orthogonality it
the only thing it requires is that m is
smaller
or equal to d so the number of omegas
you sample
is going to be smaller or equal to the
dimensionality
that the original space operates in
which
let's say this will be the case in all
our experiments
okay and again these these are
exponentially small bounds which is
pretty cool i guess for you
the end user it matters that this
works and if you use all of their tricks
with the positivity
and the orthogonality so by the way this
here is where they show that see the
orthogonal mse the mean squared error is
smaller than the original one
minus some thing and as long as the sum
thing of course is greater than zero
you're going to have something that's
smaller
okay then they prove a bunch of other
things again about this kind of
this regularized sorry not regularized
i forget it's the where do you divide by
the norm
in any case they implement this
in jax oh great wow cool
um i okay i have no opinion on jax um
but uh they have the code
released and i'll of course link to it
and here you can
clearly see so this is a log log plot
um where you have l the size of the
input
and the number of seconds that it takes
to
go forward and backward over here in the
model
and you can see the x here
the x is the baseline
where you simply bypass the attention
matrix you simply take the identity
function and
just return the value matrix and you can
see that the performance
the performers they scale fairly well
with that baseline and in fact they
scale
at the same slope which is the important
part right here you can really see that
this is
linear slope where the transformers
which are the dashed lines
they all curve upwards um
which of course is that that quadratic
requirement
uh the same in the backward pass i don't
know if they continue curving i think
it's also a straight line
in the log log plot but the slope is two
instead of one like the um
the linear like the linear models
again the comparison is only important
between the baseline
and the lines that you're looking at if
they have the same slope they scale
the same as you get higher look at this
this is log
l right so this is these these are now 2
to the 18th
uh tokens and i believe this is done on
one gpu yes so an out of memory error on
a v100
gpu and uh
this is pretty good this is pretty good
news for everyone who wants to
run the the performers in
in kind of a low resource environment
low reason with low resource i mean
uh like a deep learning gpu instead of a
thousand
tpus which is pretty cool
they they also show the that their
method is better than
the kind of so the orthogonality is
better than the iid
features and then of course the positive
iid features are better than this
original
trigonometric decomposition and
they show that this
thing that you can take a transformer
checkpoint and you plug it into
the performer and
you simply have to fine-tune a little
bit to
get it to the performance that the
transformer was at right this is
i believe this is the original training
curve of the transformer
so you know it's not a fair comparison
because the performer starts from the
checkpoint
already at least that's how i interpret
it it's not clearly written and they
say okay over here this trig
thing works this is the original
approximation this even works
however if we do that on a bit more
challenging
more longer sequences uh data data set
then you can see that the trig softmax
it just it just whacks out that's this
thing here
and you actually need uh better these
positive approximations now to compare
to the linformer here
which is pretty cool so the linformer
another
i've made a video about it if you want
to know about it but they also do
random projections of the attention
matrix
but you can see that the linformer
plateaus
along with the performers if you don't
redraw the random features so if you
want
in the performer if you do it at the
right time you redraw
these random features these omegas
you have to you have to see where you
can you can't just arbitrarily redraw
them between computation steps but at
the end of like a computation step you
can redraw for the next computation step
and if you do that and
the even better with the regularized or
the the
normalized features you get to the same
level of performance that a standard
transformer
would get but of course without the
quadratic
requirements
and okay lastly as i said they've
already they've already swapped out
the um they swapped out
this non-linearity by a relu
so here they construct performer relu
taking f equals relu in equation five
you remember what
f was f was the sine and cosine
when we had the first approximation and
f was the x
x of u and x above minus u the second
one
and as i said uh the big improvement
in deep learning came when we swapped
sigmoids for
relus and here they've already they're
already trying swapping now this because
they say well
so we have a method that we can
basically plug in anything we want
so they plug in relu because it's you
know worked well and
this again it works pretty well
so they compare again also with the
reformer here
with the lin former as you can see and
of course they beat everything now
whether or not this method is going to
be the next
thing like the thing that everyone uses
is to be
we don't know um it's fairly possible
it's pretty cool and it appears to be
theoretically
solidly grounded but you never know from
the experiments of the single paper
the broader impact statement much
respect they just use it to tell you how
awesome their paper is
like there's no mention on on
on any kind of uh ethical impact
which i believe like i'm all for these
kinds of broader impact statements like
just
kind of okay research on transformers is
going to be better because now people
have access to it it's backward
compatible that's pretty cool
uh it's applicable to biology and
medicine because we can now
take a longer sequences it's all like
yeah
i like these kinds of broader impact
statement the last
thing here is that you might be
um so the the only problem is if you
want to do this
causal attention that if you want to do
like a generative model like a gpt
sort of model you have to do a bit of a
trick
and that is because your attention
matrix isn't the full attention matrix
right so you can't just decompose it
it's this lower triangular matrix right
here
but since you have linear decomposition
of this thing you can do these kind of
prefix sums namely
you can compute simply so
uh you you
you can compute the key one
times value one and then you can compute
key
two times value two plus
key one times value one and you compute
key three value three plus key two
value two plus key one sorry
value one and so on you compute these
things and these are all
these are all the big where the l goes
away right
so we do that first and then we simply
have to
come along and we take q
q1 multiply by k1
v1 we take q2 multiply by this
and this q3 will multiply by this
this and this and you see that's how you
get your causal attention so
you simply keep track of these prefix
sums
right here and then when the next q
comes along you simply multiply it by
all of the things
that are above it in the prefix sum
that's how you get your triangular
matrix
so even that is solved a thing
that i believe the linformer wasn't able
to do
with its particular decomposition i
might be i might be wrong here
all right they have a bunch of
experiments on protein analysis and so
on which of course wasn't
possible i guess before because it was
so
so heavy they also have like imagenet 64
as you can see right here which
is an impossible data set for a classic
transformer
as i said they have code code is in jax
which is
like this is it it's ugly code uh let's
be honest
but it's code so that's fairly cool
and i want to point out the right at the
bottom here is actually where the
stuff happens so you can see
that just quickly
you have here keys and queries are
where is it exact so the queries and
keys
are going to be constructed right here
so query prime and key prime
are going to be pulled through this
feature creator which implements these
these kernels so these can be either as
we said these x
or the release or the sine cosine
what not then you're going to
multiply the queries and the keys which
gives you
yep this w matrix
and all that we need to do now is
normalize it
okay so we re-normalize
by constructing this denominator right
here
and then there's a whole block for the
unidirectionality
which you can imagine is pretty ugly but
the renormalization we constructed we
reciprocal means we
take the inverse multiply it by the w
and return
the result this should be translatable
into
your favorite what not pi torch or
tensorflow maybe it's already
been done i haven't researched that
particular thing
in any case i invite you to check out
the paper
the code play around with the functions
used here
as long as you you know use phone you
don't even you don't need to know like
these papers they always
know which kind of kernels their
functions correspond to but
you know in svms people just went when
nuts i
just plug in some functions see what
happens
probably nothing good but um it's
possible
all right so that was it for the per
former
i hope you gained something from this um
kind of an understanding of how it works
and
i wish you the best bye